nine-one-one what is your emergency we  were in the middle of rehearsal in the  middle of a scene I heard some shot it  was like being in a war zone  [Music]  first everyone was still trying to  figure out how to process all of this  you always hear if the show must go on  when we all came back to school we all  knew what we needed to do this was  something we had to finish especially  something like this which is for kids  this is our begin again it is the most  important show that you're doing  probably ever we had to finish this to  show our community that we can't move on  we want to bring happiness to the school  again even though these bad things have  happened to us beautiful things can come  out of it deep the darkest stuff to make  him back to school I said I promise you  life is so good  [Music]  you